dude have you seen making a murder here
I was just about to ask you avenged it
last night it's incredible so good I'm
so good has anyone seen in last time I
saw him it was yesterday
he was talking to Alaska someone has to
find out what happened to Ned
he always had a smile on his face he
could really count on a guy like Ned
just like brighten your day he loved his
job he loved his wife to think that
someone could do something like this to
a guy like that makes my blood boil the
morning they brought in Timothy
Treadstone it just it all started to
make sense of course it'd be him
you want snow blaster I didn't do it
st. the first time Alaska got himself in
trouble Alaska's the kind of guy that
yeah maybe he had some shady parts in
his past stealing people's lunches
unplugging people's computers he ain't a
saint but that don't make him a murderer
I've seen making a murderer
I think I'd know a murderer if I saw one
what's going on I think it's me hasn't I
know that well uh you're gonna be home
late tonight or something I don't know I
got a problem with me hate me or
something
well you'll keep your chin up high over
there and we'll keep it up high over
here yeah all right I love you
you know my roommate didn't do it he was
set up so we done got the best people in
the office to represent him
what makes in the best you know day were
the first ones to finish making a
murderer so they know what better than
anyone how are you I didn't see them
plant the evidence no but given all the
misinformation and outright slander
surrounding this employee plus my
background and legal expertise having
watched making a murderer it wouldn't
surprise me one bit if there was
corruption at work here I promise
nothing bad will happen to you if you
just say I shot Ned I don't think I
should do that
I shot Ned say it or I will hurt you
high shot Ned alright why would you make
me say that so his co-workers had the
motivation to get him fired and lo and
behold you got this his try guys is gold
me goose disappears out of thin air and
who was the last person to see him is
AHA mister Treadstone sounds a lot like
made you murderer to me has anyone
actually tried contacting Ned like
stopping by his house your muna McCall I
don't know hey man what's up
Neddy you're alive where are you I'm at
home keep this between us but I finally
started watching making a murderer and
I'm taking a personal day to finish it
so good
am i rest that's not Ned what do you
mean would you ever pick up the phone
while binge watching an episode of
making the murderer oh my god